I know that you are expecting yours your
second child second congratulations
that's fantastic I'm very curious about
parenting style I'm like out of breath
sorry you're out of breath from rocking
from here to there don't touch the
ground oh that's true they don't I'm
pregnant
okay well we'll get you out of here as
fast as possible you're probably
backstage yelling at someone what am i
why am I doing this no I know that
you're you're expecting your second
child
how old is your first he's 21 months so
that means like almost two yeah just say
- you're gonna stop I love parents that
keep that going for a really long time
he's a hundred and ninety eight months
he's 44 big difference what they can do
at 21 months versus two years yes I
remember I have two who are older now
they're in their late fifties before I
was born but no I'm just curious like it
all comes down to parenting style like
with your first child with you and your
husband do you know like what the
parenting styles are I mean like how you
differ safe oh yeah we differ yeah I
mean mainly like I do things for the
child that the child wants and needs yes
like you know I listen to wheels on the
bus and read him like you know one fish
two fish green fish and Ryan will listen
to car D be like whatever he wants to
listen to and like reads him like you
know a brief history of time yeah it's
annoying
right so he's doing the things he wants
to do what the child he would do anyway
the child can like it or not and then
you are actually thinking about the
child's well-being that is the
difference
these are gender differences I was I was
totally yeah I was my wife would do all
the things that the the baby needed to
survive and live and have a productive
life and then I was an ass all the time
well you know and I also like always
think of like the future like what kind
of person am i creating like I know you
don't want to sit here and eat your
dinner
but like you're gonna learn this sit
here and eat your dinner and we'll
breathe through it and you're not gonna
like it and maybe I'm not gonna but
we're gonna get through it
and Ryan like out like if he hasn't for
the morning I'm like how do you for
breakfast he's like he ate great I'm
like he sat there at 8:00 he's like well
no I put him in the bathtub and fed him
in the bathtub you what why the bathtub
because chilly I'm in the tub because
he's distracted I'm having a great time
and then he just shoves food and it's
not crazy it's absolutely nuts I don't
know I mean so that that works it
actually works I mean I guess if he got
food in him then that's enough what I
used to do with my daughter was when she
was you know a couple you know like when
she was about a year old or so a little
older than that and she wouldn't eat the
broccoli whatever I would say this is my
broccoli you know but he touched my
broccoli and then I would turn my back
and she would just for the fun of
stealing it eat the broccoli and that'd
be like who took my broccoli and I
thought that was a great idea and now
she's 16 and she steals that didn't work
out she gets out soon broccoli that's
all she feels well steal broccoli but a
lot of it hundreds of Rallo